Buonasera. Dunque, come scoppiano le guerre? Qualche mese fa, quando abbiamo cominciato
a pensare che cosa potevo venire a raccontare qui a Sarzana, c'era già un po' il clima
che in fondo c'è ancora anche adesso, c'erano già notizie dall'Ucraina, c'erano notizie
dall'Iraq, diciamo che Papa Francesco non aveva ancora detto la terza guerra mondiale
è già scoppiata, invece adesso poco tempo fa l'ha detto. E insomma è sempre più attuale
evidentemente chiedersi com'è, ecco, devo ripetere la prima parte? No, tanto è solo un modo per
entrare in argomento, va bene lo stesso. Come scoppiano le guerre? In realtà quello che
vi racconterò io credo che sia anche abbastanza rassicurante, nel senso che mostra che le guerre
scoppiano, le grandi guerre mondiali scoppiano in situazioni abbastanza diverse da quella
che stiamo vivendo adesso. Oggi stiamo vivendo una situazione internazionale disastrosa, piena
di sofferenza, piena di incertezze, ma insomma abbastanza diversa dagli scenari che si prospettavano
nell'Europa, per esempio nell'Europa del 1914, da cui cominciamo stasera. Come scoppia la
prima guerra mondiale? Beh, in fondo lo sappiamo tutti, comincia con un attentato, l'attentato
di Sarajevo. Il 28 giugno del 1914 un gruppo di terroristi serbi uccide l'arciduca Francesco
Ferdinando, che è l'erede al trono dell'impero austriaco. Allora, la prima cosa importante da dire
sullo scoppio della prima guerra mondiale è che è nata da un atto di terrorismo e il terrorismo,
anche allora come oggi, provocava delle reazioni viscerali nell'opinione pubblica e quindi
anche nei governi. Un atto di terrorismo a noi oggi può sembrare che ammazzare un'arciduca
tutto sommato sia forse una cosa un po' meno grave che non, che so, abbattere due grattacieli
con 3.000 persone dentro. E invece una prima cosa che dobbiamo avere ben chiara per capire
come era fatta la gente del 1914 e che per loro, almeno per i politici di allora, ammazzare
un'arciduca, erede al trono dell'impero, è una cosa molto più grave che non abbattere
due grattacieli se mai loro avessero potuto immaginarselo. Provate a pensare, l'impero
austro-ungarico è una grande potenza, è ancora una grande potenza indebolita, in crisi,
ma è una delle poche grandi potenze mondiali. Nell'impero austro-ungarico governa l'imperatore
Francesco Giuseppe. L'imperatore Francesco Giuseppe ha 84 anni, il che vuol dire che morirà
prestissimo. Nessuno sa quando, ma è sicuro che morirà prestissimo. Francesco Giuseppe
regna da tempo immemorabile sull'impero austriaco, regna da 66 anni. Morirà prestissimo, questo
lo sanno tutti, in effetti poi morirà nel dicembre del 16, un anno e mezzo dopo, questo
lo sappiamo noi. E quando morirà Francesco Giuseppe, l'arciduca Francesco Ferdinando diventerà
il sovrano di una delle grandi potenze mondiali, per tutta la vita. Voi capite che ammazzarlo
cambia un po'. Non è come ammazzare un Presidente degli Stati Uniti, che tanto dopo quattro anni
se ne fa un altro. Qui si ammazza uno che per tutta la vita avrebbe contribuito a governare
il mondo. Quindi l'attentato è gravissimo, è un atto di terrorismo di una gravità enorme
e ha complicità all'estero. Qui dobbiamo ricordarci com'è, io passerò tutta la serata
a dirvi, dobbiamo ricordarci questa cosa, mi scuserete, non è così semplice come scoppia
una guerra, c'è tutta una serie di collegamenti. La prima messa a fuoco, Sarajevo, perché Sarajevo?
Sarajevo in Bosnia. E la Bosnia è allora, come anche nel nostro tempo, un luogo delicato.
Anche allora la Bosnia è un luogo dove c'è una mescolanza etnica, etnie ostili. La Bosnia
da qualche anno è stata occupata dall'Austria-Ungheria e alcuni degli abitanti sono contenti, la popolazione
croata è contenta, per esempio. La popolazione bosniaca musulmana è ben contenta di appartenere
all'impero austriaco, tant'è vero che i soldati bosnici musulmani combatteranno nella
prima guerra mondiale fedelmente per l'impero, anche in Italia, questi reggimenti musulmani
colfez. E invece in Serbia, in Bosnia, c'è una percentuale di popolazione serba che non
è contenta per niente di appartenere all'Austria. Perché lì accanto c'è la Serbia, il regno
di Serbia, la Serbia indipendente, piccola ma bellicosa, uno stato agguerrito, con tradizioni
militari, con grandi sogni di espansione. I serbi di Bosnia soffrono di essere sotto l'impero
austriaco. E quindi c'è malcontento e c'è terrorismo. E questo terrorismo gli austriaci
sono sicuri che è appoggiato, sostenuto, organizzato in Serbia. Che questo attentato
in cui è stato ammazzato l'Arciduca e sua moglie è stato organizzato in Serbia con complicità
nel governo serbo, nell'esercito serbo. Gli austriaci sono sicuri fin dal primo giorno.
fra l'altro è vero. Verrà fuori dalle indagini, non c'è dubbio. Ci sono queste complicità
in Serbia. E dunque l'Austria è decisa a punire la Serbia. E qui veramente voi dovete
fare lo sforzo di pensare non l'Austria, la Serbia, stati dimenticati come erano allora,
chi si ricorda più? No. Qui c'è lo Stato canaglia che organizza il terrorismo all'estero.
e c'è chi ha subito l'attentato terroristico che è deciso a punire lo Stato canaglia. In
Austria c'è un'ondata di indignazione, di massa. Le folle sono in piazza a gridare
la Serbia deve morire. In tedesco fa anche assonanza. Serbien muss sterben. Però c'è
un problema. La Serbia ha un grande amico, ha un grande protettore. La Russia. La Russia
dello zar Nicola II. L'amicizia fra la Serbia e la Russia è una cosa, è un dato ovvio della
geografia europea, è vero anche oggi. La Russia è una potenza slava, ortodossa. I serbi sono
giugoslavi, ortodossi. Anche nelle guerre jugoslave degli anni novanta la Russia spalleggiava
la Serbia. Allarghiamo un attimo il discorso. La Serbia ha un grande amico, la Russia. Tutti
in quel mondo del 1914 cercano di avere degli amici, degli alleati. È un aspetto fondamentale
il peso delle alleanze per capire come mai si scivola nella guerra mondiale. Perché
quello non è un mondo di blocchi. Ormai non lo è più neanche il nostro, è rimasto solo
il blocco americano, ma insomma tutti ci ricordiamo quando il nostro mondo era diviso in due blocchi
e al di fuori dei due blocchi non si faceva niente. Il mondo del 1914 non è così. È un
mondo di potenze grandi e piccole. Quali sono le grandi potenze? L'Inghilterra, la Germania,
la Francia, la Russia, l'Austria e Ungheria. Poi per cortesia ci si mette anche l'Italia
di solito. Ultima delle grandi potenze con un po' di sforzo. E poi ci sono le piccole
potenze, ma anche loro bellicose nazionaliste, agguerrite, la Serbia, la Romania, il Belgio.
Non sono divise in blocchi. Ognuno pensa per sé. È l'epoca in cui il nazionalismo è
al massimo. Ogni paese è convinto di avere il dovere di pensare per sé.
E' quello che un politico italiano, il Presidente del Consiglio Salandra, proprio in quei giorni
definirà il sacro egoismo. Però se uno deve pensare per sé, deve anche cercare di avere
degli alleati. Perché da soli si finisce male. Quindi ciascuno per la propria sicurezza
cerca di avere delle alleanze. La Serbia è alleata della Russia. Gli austriaci pensano
che insomma il mondo capirà. La Serbia è chiaramente uno stato canaglia che ha organizzato
il terrorismo. Va punita per la sicurezza di tutti. Però il dubbio gli viene che forse
se l'Austria attacca la Serbia i russi potrebbero intervenire. Ma anche l'Austria è un amico potente.
Più potente di lei perché l'Austria è un grande impero in declino tutto sommato. Un po' tutti
lo sospettano che sia in declino. E invece l'Austria è un amico potentissimo che sta diventando
la più grande potenza mondiale, la Germania. La Germania del Kaiser Guglielmo, lo ricordate
Guglielmo con i baffoni a manubrio, l'elmo chiodato? Ma al di là del Kaiser che è una figura
un po' comica, la Germania è una grandissima potenza. Ha il più forte esercito del mondo
e sta costruendo la più forte industria del mondo. Anzi è già diventata la Germania la più
grande potenza industriale. Ha già sorpassato l'Inghilterra. L'Austria è alleata della Germania
con un'alleanza che impegna i due paesi ad aiutarsi se uno dei due viene aggredito.
A dire la verità l'alleanza comprenderebbe anche l'Italia. Infatti non per niente si chiama
la triplice alleanza. Però in quei giorni di crisi del 14 si vede benissimo che all'Italia
non ci crede nessuno. Gli austriaci non ci credono che se loro fanno la guerra l'Italia
verrà ad aiutarli. Lo tagliano e escludono proprio a priori questo discorso. E infatti
hanno ragione. L'Italia, in nome del sacro egoismo, deciderà di star fuori per il momento.
Ma c'è la Germania. L'Austria ha abbastanza buon senso da sapere che prima di fare qualcosa
contro la Serbia bisogna chiedere cosa pensano i tedeschi. Il 3 luglio ci sono i funerali di
Francesco Ferdinando. Il giorno dopo, il 4 luglio, l'imperatore, il vecchio imperatore
Francesco Giuseppe scrive al Kaiser Guglielmo dicendogli... Ecco è molto interessante questa
lettera dell'imperatore d'Austria. Non è precisa, lucida, non dice vogliamo fare questo.
È una lettera più o meno di questo genere. Dice Francesco Giuseppe a Guglielmo
lo vedi anche tu che così non si può andare avanti. La Serbia è un focolaio criminale,
va punita, anche se la Russia la protegge, non sei d'accordo? Ecco è una lettera che a me fa
pensare alle motivazioni con cui gli occidentali sono andati in Iraq o in Afghanistan dopo l'11
settembre. Cioè bisogna fare qualcosa. Non è che c'è un ragionamento lucido sulle conseguenze,
quella che oggi si chiama una exit strada. No, non sei d'accordo che bisogna fare qualcosa.
Per fortuna dell'Austria il Kaiser Guglielmo è d'accordo. Quando gli è arrivata la notizia
dell'attentato di Sarajevo, il Kaiser Guglielmo sul telegramma ha annotato
sarebbe veramente ora di far piazza pulita dei serbi. Di conseguenza il 5 luglio il Kaiser
Guglielmo risponde al suo collega austriaco dicendogli andate avanti, state tranquilli,
se la Russia dovesse intromettersi la Germania sta con voi. Ma il Kaiser aggiunge anche però
state davvero tranquilli, i russi non avranno il coraggio di intromettersi. Noi siamo sicuri,
la Russia starà fuori. È la prima scommessa. La storia di stasera è una storia di scommesse,
una dopo l'altra, tutte sbagliate. E come dire, come vedremo le guerre scoppiano,
non perché qualcuno le vuole, non le vuole mai nessuno la guerra, perlomeno non la guerra mondiale,
la guerra generale, mai nessuno la vuole. Le guerre scoppiano perché qualcuno fa una
scommessa sbagliata. Mi fermo ancora un momento su questa assicurazione che il Kaiser Guglielmo
manda al suo collega austriaco andate avanti, noi siamo con voi, state tranquilli. È una
rassicurazione che gli storici hanno poi chiamato l'assegno in bianco. Come è stato dato questo
assegno in bianco? La Germania è già un paese parlamentare, ci sono i partiti, il Parlamento,
le libere elezioni. Il Kaiser non ha sentito nessuno. Ha scritto lui, prima ancora di consultare
chiunque, al suo collega l'imperatore d'Austria, dicendo vai tranquillo. Poi il Kaiser ha sentito
qualcuno, chi? Il Parlamento, ma neanche per idea. Ha sentito il cancelliere, il primo ministro
cioè? Ha sentito il comandante dell'esercito, il generale von Moltke, e il generale von Moltke
gli ha detto se scoppia una guerra noi siamo pronti. E poi questo è interessante, chi ha
sentito ancora il Kaiser Guglielmo? Ha sentito Alfred Krupp, il grande industriale delle armi.
La Krupp è la più grande fabbrica di armi del mondo. Il Kaiser ha sentito il bisogno di
consultare Alfred Krupp. Se mai dovesse scoppiare una guerra le industrie Krupp sono pronte? E
Alfred Krupp l'ha rassicurato, le industrie Krupp sono pronte. Però sono sicuri che la
guerra non scoppierà, tant'è vero che il Kaiser, dopo aver mandato l'assegno in bianco
a Vienna, si imbarca sul suo yacht e va in crociera nel Baltico. Siamo a luglio, la gente
vuole fare le vacanze e anche il Kaiser parte in vacanza. Questa scommessa tedesca, che la
guerra sì c'è un rischio ma vedrete che la guerra non verrà, è un aspetto cruciale
del discorso che dobbiamo fare stasera e perciò mi devo ancora fermare su questo. La scommessa
è una scommessa ancora più grossa di quello che sembra, per la questione delle alleanze,
perché in ballo non c'è solo la Russia, la Russia è il grande amico della Serbia, ma
la Russia ha un'alleanza con la Francia, è un'alleanza innaturale dal punto di vista
politico, se ci pensate, la Francia, la Repubblica laica, anticlericale, radicale e l'impero
dello zar, l'impero ortodosso, lo stato più assolutista e reazionario che ci sia sul
continente, è un'alleanza innaturale, eppure da vent'anni sono alleati la Francia e la
Russia. Perché? E basta guardare la carta geografica, la carta geografica di allora.
Oggi a noi sembra che la Germania sia una grande potenza. La Germania di allora era molto
più grande. Non esisteva la Polonia, non esisteva la Cecoslovacchia, non esistevano gli
stati baltici, c'era solo la Germania e a un certo punto la Russia. Sulla carta d'Europa
del XIV c'è la Germania in mezzo che confina con la Francia e con la Russia. E allora è
chiaro che la Francia e la Russia hanno tutto l'interesse a essere alleati. E i tedeschi,
quando scommettono che non ci sarà la guerra, che non ci sarà la guerra mondiale, quella
piccola dell'Austria con la Serbia, sì certo va benissimo, ci vuole, ma quando scommettono
che non ci sarà la guerra, i tedeschi stanno scommettendo che non ci sarà la guerra contro
Russia e Francia, perché il rischio è quello. Come mai corrono questo rischio?
La seconda parte di questo discorso, di questa chiacchierata, sarà una specie di conto alla
rovescia, gli ultimi giorni, ma prima dobbiamo tracciare un quadro più ampio, farvi entrare
nella testa di quella gente che governa il mondo in quel momento. Com'è il mondo, com'è
l'Europa in quel momento? L'Europa del 1914 sta vivendo una fase di grande prosperità,
di grande espansione economica. Dopo i decenni di crisi economica della fine dell'Ottocento,
l'economia ha ricominciato a tirare, stanno crescendo tutti, c'è perfino una specie di
globalizzazione antelittera, ma vabbè oggi è molto facile trovare le globalizzazioni nel
passato, io ne ho viste di tutti i tipi, anche l'impero romano era una globalizzazione,
ma comunque questa del 1914 ha i tratti di una globalizzazione, le economie sono interdipendenti,
le borse sono interdipendenti, le monete sono collegate, sono ancorate all'oro, la lira
italiana vale esattamente quanto il franco francese, si viaggia in tutta Europa senza
passaporto, tranne in Russia, in Russia ci vuole il passaporto per entrarci, ma per il resto
questa Europa è così interdipendente che sembra incredibile che possa scoppiare una guerra
fra queste potenze, eppure al tempo stesso tutti questi paesi, anche l'Italia, sono armati
fino ai denti, hanno tutti delle spese militari di un livello paragonabile a quelle americane
di oggi, spendono somme enormi per l'esercito, per la flotta da guerra, e perché lo fanno?
Lo fanno perché hanno paura gli uni degli altri. Un aspetto importante per capire la mentalità
delle classi dirigenti di quell'epoca è che sono tutti imbevuti di una specie di ideologia
darwiniana, ma molto semplificata, la sopravvivenza del più adatto, la lotta per la sopravvivenza,
la sopravvivenza del più forte. Loro sono convinti che anche gli stati sono in lotta fra
loro in questo modo, i più forti trionferanno, i più deboli saranno mangiati. E siccome sono
convinti di questo, ognuno vuole essere forte, e tutti si armano per sopravvivere. Nessuno si
immagina di essere l'aggressore in futuro, sono sempre gli altri gli aggressori. Noi siamo
minacciati, dobbiamo essere forti, dobbiamo avere un grande esercito, e siccome spendiamo
una quantità enorme di soldi per un grande esercito, e beh, dobbiamo prevedere che forse
prima o poi lo useremo. Non può essere escluso, anzi, è abbastanza probabile, dice qualcuno.
Quelli sono anni, è impressionante, perché in quegli anni escono libri che parlano tranquillamente
della prossima guerra. È uno scenario prevedibile, fa parte dell'orizzonte. Nel 1911 è uscito
in Germania un libro di un generale tedesco, il generale von Bernardi, che si intitola
La Germania è la prossima guerra. Mancano tre anni alla prima guerra mondiale. In questo
libro ci sono dei capitoli che si intitolano Il diritto di fare la guerra, il dovere di
fare la guerra, dominare il mondo o perire. Ho fatto un esempio tedesco perché i generali
tedeschi sono particolarmente propensi a esplicitare questi discorsi, ma in realtà in tutti i paesi
si facevano discorsi simili. E' ben inteso, non tutti ragionavano così, c'era anche qualcuno
lucido che diceva ma guardate che con le economie interdipendenti che abbiamo fare una guerra fra
le grandi potenze sarebbe una catastrofe. Vi cito ancora un libro uscito in quegli anni,
sono i libri che leggevano i primi ministri e i comandanti degli eserciti, ce li avevano
sul comodino. Nel 1910 esce un libro di un pubblicista inglese, Norman Angel, che si intitola
La Grande Illusione. Ricordate il film La Grande Illusione? Beh ha poi copiato il titolo da questo
libro che al suo tempo era molto famoso. La Grande Illusione cos'è? L'autore dice che la Grande Illusione
è proprio quella delle nostre grandi potenze che credono che avere un grande esercito e prepararsi
a vincere la prossima guerra sia una garanzia, non è così. La prossima guerra la perderemo
tutti, dice questo autore. La prossima guerra distruggerà anche i vincitori, è un'illusione
credere che la forza ci salverà. Ora, libri come questo circolano, i politici li leggono
e nell'Europa del 14 diversi politici si erano abbastanza convinti che in effetti una
guerra tra le grandi potenze sarebbe stata una catastrofe. Però il paradosso è che questi
politici erano alla testa di paesi armati fino ai denti.
era talmente prevedibile lo scenario della prossima guerra che a un certo punto è successa
questa cosa, vi racconto questo particolare. A Londra, a un certo punto il ministro degli
esteri inglese Sir Edward Gray, parlando con l'ambasciatore tedesco, il principe Liknovsky,
a un certo punto il ministro degli esteri inglese Gray dice all'ambasciatore tedesco
sentite questa conversazione, se scoppiasse una guerra europea per un attacco austriaco
alla Serbia e la Russia spinta dall'opinione pubblica marciasse contro l'Austria, costringendo
in tal modo la Germania a andare in soccorso dell'Austria, la Francia sarebbe inevitabilmente
coinvolta e nessuno sa dove si potrebbe arrivare. E la descrizione di quello che vi sto raccontando
stasera, la crisi di Sarajevo, la crisi dell'estate del 14, solo che questa conversazione è avvenuta
due anni prima. Nel dicembre del 12 Gray ha detto queste cose all'ambasciatore tedesco.
Gli scenari sono quelli. Dove può scoppiare una guerra? Sono pochi i posti. I Balcani sono
un posto tipico con tutti i disordini che ci sono. Ora, a partire dal fatto che lo scenario
della prossima guerra è prevedibile, si crea però una spaccatura fra i politici e i militari.
Perché i politici dicono guardate questo scenario, dobbiamo fare di tutto per evitarlo, sarebbe
una catastrofe se si realizzasse. Ma i militari hanno un altro mestiere. Il mestiere dei militari
è di dire e se invece succede noi cosa facciamo? Se invece succede noi dobbiamo essere pronti.
Perciò i militari in quegli anni di grande crescita economica premono tutti questi soldi,
usiamoli, usiamoli per essere più forti. E i politici cedono. Gli anni che precedono
il 14 sono anni di corsa agli armamenti in cui ogni paese, non perché voglia aggredire
qualcuno ma perché è preoccupato per la sua sicurezza, rafforza il suo esercito. Nell'agosto
del 13, dieci mesi prima dell'attentato di Sarajevo, la Francia passa una legge per cui il
servizio militare, il servizio di leva viene innalzato da due a tre anni. Immaginate un
mondo in cui il servizio di leva dura tre anni. Cosa dicono i tedeschi quando il Parlamento
francese vota la legge che aumenta il servizio di leva? I tedeschi dicono ah i francesi vogliono
fare la guerra, ci minacciano. È una reazione molto comprensibile che i politologi hanno studiato,
è una reazione che si chiama il paradosso della sicurezza. Io voglio essere più sicuro,
quindi mi armo, i miei vicini si spaventano, si sentono meno sicuri di prima, quindi si armano
anche loro e così via e così via. Penultima cosa prima di arrivare, tornare all'Austria che
sta decidendo cosa fare contro la Serbia. Penultima cosa per aver chiaro il quadro di quel momento.
I militari non si limitano a chiedere più armi, fanno anche un'altra cosa, il loro mestiere è di
dire se succede davvero la guerra noi dobbiamo essere pronti. Essere pronti vuol dire fare dei
piani. Nel 1914 le grandi potenze non si fanno più la guerra fra loro da un sacco di tempo, dalla
guerra di Crimea, dalla guerra franco-prussiana, sono passati quasi 50 anni. In quei 50 anni gli stati
maggiori non hanno fatto altro che preparare piani. Se scoppia la guerra, quella guerra lì contro quel
nemico lì, noi cosa facciamo? Ci sono i piani pronti per tutte le guerre possibili, dettagliatissimi,
precisissimi, ogni anno li riaprono, vanno a precisare, aggiustare un dettaglio, per 50 anni
li hanno perfezionati. Ci sono i piani pronti per tutto. Un aneddoto a questo proposito. Nel novembre
del 1913. Mancano otto mesi all'attentato di Sarajevo. Il re del Belgio è in visita di stato
a Berlino. C'è un ricevimento e durante il ricevimento il Kaiser Guglielmo indica un generale
al re del Belgio e gli dice quello è l'uomo che comanderà la marcia su Parigi. I piani sono talmente
completi che è già tutto deciso. Perfino chi comanderà ogni singola armata e così via è tutto
pronto se dovesse venire la guerra. Finalmente, ultima cosa prima di tornare a Vienna dove stanno
discutendo su esattamente cosa chiedere ai serbi e come fare per dargli una bella lezione. Ultima
cosa. Questa corsa agli armamenti di questi anni ha un'altra caratteristica che la rende molto
pericolosa che permette di prevedere l'evoluzione dei rapporti di forza. Gli armamenti sono cose
lente. Imposti una corazzata sarà pronta fra cinque anni. Aumenti di un anno il servizio di
leva e prima che si senta passano due anni e così via e così via. Perciò ognuno sta molto attento.
Noi, quando è che saremo al massimo della forza? E loro? La Russia, per esempio, è debole
militarmente in quel momento dopo la guerra russo-giapponese, però sta facendo grandissimi
investimenti. Fra qualche anno sarà molto più forte. Allora in questo clima, voi capite, i militari
fanno il loro mestiere. Il loro mestiere è di dire se ci sarà la guerra noi dobbiamo essere pronti.
e a proposito, se ci sarà la guerra, a noi quando conviene che ci sia? Ci conviene che sia presto o ci
conviene che sia più tardi? Tutti i militari fanno questi calcoli. E poi ogni tanto qualcosa cambia.
Nell'aprile 1914 si viene a sapere che la Russia e l'Inghilterra stanno negoziando un accordo navale.
L'Inghilterra, finora non l'ho quasi menzionata, non ha alleanze l'Inghilterra, ci tornerò subito.
Ma adesso sta cominciando dei colloqui con la Russia. Voi capite che effetto fa questo a Berlino?
A Berlino dicono abbiamo già la Russia e la Francia alleate fra loro contro di noi nella prossima
guerra, quando verrà. Se anche l'Inghilterra dovesse allearsi con loro, per noi la situazione è peggiora.
Questi colloqui tra russi e inglesi cominciano ad aprile. A maggio del 1914 il comandante
dell'esercito tedesco von Moltke dichiara, in privato, non in pubblico, da questo momento
ogni giorno di ritardo potrà solo diminuire le nostre probabilità di successo. Qualche settimana
ancora? Il primo giugno del 1914 von Moltke dichiara, ora siamo pronti e più presto è, meglio è.
Mancano quattro settimane all'attentato di Sarajevo. L'ha organizzato von Moltke l'attentato
di Sarajevo. No, evidentemente. È il catalizzatore che fa venire fuori tutte queste cose che sono
state lì a bollire per anni. Torniamo a Vienna, dove stanno preparando l'ultimatum da mandare
alla Serbia. Manderanno un ultimatum durissimo perché gli austriaci non vogliono che i serbi
lo accettino. Gli austriaci vogliono la guerra e hanno un assegno in bianco della Germania. Sarà
un ultimatum pesantissimo. I tedeschi premono. I tedeschi premono con Vienna dicendo fate in fretta,
mettete il mondo davanti al fatto compiuto. Prima fate, meglio è. I russi non oseranno intervenire.
Ma l'Austria è un paese dove le cose si fanno con calma. È un paese dove le cose sono
fatte con lentezza. Ci sono due governi, quell'austriaco e quell'ungherese. Devono mettersi
d'accordo. E poi l'esercito austriaco è un esercito lento, arretrato. Ci mette tanto tempo
per prepararsi. Oltretutto, pensate, è una cosa che oggi non penserebbe nessuno. È luglio. È l'epoca
del raccolto. I soldati sono tutti a casa in licenza. L'Austria è un paese agricolo per raccogliere
il grano. Ci vuole tempo. Gli austriaci non hanno fretta. A Berlino fremono. Stiamo sempre
a rimorchio di questo paese arretrato. Finalmente, il 23 luglio, quasi un mese dopo, l'ultimatum
austriaco è pronto. Viene consegnato al governo serbo. È un ultimatum durissimo. Gli austriaci
ci dicono alla Serbia. Il governo serbo non ha fatto niente per impedire il proliferare
del terrorismo. Ufficiali e funzionari serbi sono coinvolti nell'attentato di Sarajevo.
Perciò noi austriaci vogliamo che il governo serbo pubblichi una dichiarazione in cui si
dissocia da ogni forma di ostilità all'Austria. Il governo serbo dovrà chiudere tutti i giornali
e sciogliere tutte le associazioni che seminano odio contro l'Austria. Il governo serbo dovrà
licenziare tutti i funzionari pubblici e gli ufficiali che sono in qualche modo coinvolti
con forme di ostilità contro l'Austria. Dovrà far arrestare queste persone. Gli austriaci presentano
l'elenco. E dovrà aprire indagini contro il terrorismo su territorio serbo a cui parteciperanno
inquirenti austriaci. Il 24 luglio le capitali di tutto il mondo si svegliano con la notizia
di questo ultimatum e l'ultimatum viene accolto malissimo. A Pietroburgo il ministro degli
esteri russo convoca l'ambasciatore austriaco e gli dice ma voi volete fare la guerra alla
Serbia. Sono i tedeschi che vi aizzano. Voi state appiccando il fuoco all'Europa. Vi
assumete una grave responsabilità. E uno per i russi la responsabilità è di Vienna e degli
austriaci. Ne vedremo tutta una serie di queste frasi. Vi assumete voi la responsabilità.
Questa è solo la prima. Anche a Londra il ministro degli esteri Gray è sterrefatto. Chiama
l'ambasciatore tedesco Liknovsky gli dice ma non ho mai visto uno stato che manda a un altro
stato un documento così. È impossibile che i serbi lo accettino. Qui c'è un piccolo dettaglio
d'epoca per dare il senso dell'epoca. Il principe Liknovsky, ambasciatore tedesco, dice ma certo
che il linguaggio dell'ultimatum è un po' duro ma voi capite è rivolto a un popolo balcanico,
mica un popolo civile. I popoli balcanici non possono essere considerati con gli stessi
criteri dei popoli civili culturfölka europei. Ora siamo a Londra dunque in questo scambio
di battute fra Gray e Liknovsky. Cosa succede a Londra? A Londra effettivamente la scommessa
dei tedeschi per il momento sembra che regga. L'opinione pubblica inglese se ne infischia
nel modo più assoluto della Serbia. L'Inghilterra non ha alleanze con nessuno. Avrebbe un'amicizia
con la Francia che dura da anni, questo va detto. I militari inglesi e francesi sono abituati
a consultarsi, hanno preparato anche dei piani insieme, hanno fatto abbastanza amicizia, ma
non ci sono obblighi, non ci sono trattati. E l'Inghilterra è un paese isolazionista in
quel momento. L'Inghilterra è un paese che domina il mondo, all'India, all'Africa, alle
colonie, il commercio, la borsa, se ne infischia delle piccole controversie continentali e in
particolare dei Balcani. I giornali inglesi in quei giorni scrivono, ma perché dovremmo
farci trascinare in una guerra di qualcun altro. C'è un giornale di Manchester in cui
esce un articolo il cui tema è «Tanto poco Belgrado si preoccupa di Manchester, altrettanto
poco Manchester si preoccupa di Belgrado». La controprova del fatto che l'Inghilterra
fino a quel momento era proprio fuori da questi pensieri sono i verbali del governo inglese,
delle riunioni di governo, dal giorno dell'attentato di Sarajevo, 28 giugno, al giorno in cui
tutto il mondo è messo a rumore perché gli austriaci hanno consegnato l'ultimatum alla
Serbia, 24 luglio, per quasi un mese il governo inglese non ha mai discusso di politica estera.
Hanno dei problemi loro, hanno l'Irlanda che non è ancora indipendente, dove c'è il terrorismo,
c'è di tutto, la rivoluzione che sta per scoppiare, la politica estera per gli inglesi
non esiste. C'è solo qualcuno in Inghilterra che ragiona diversamente, c'è qualche funzionario
del Ministero degli Esteri, noi lo sappiamo per gli appunti che si scambiano in quei giorni,
c'è qualche funzionario del Ministero degli Esteri che invece ha paura di quello che sta
succedendo, e di nuovo il paradosso della sicurezza, noi siamo abbastanza sicuri, la Germania
sta diventando molto forte. I tedeschi dicono che lo fanno solo perché hanno paura di noi,
ma però se diventano troppo forti, allora qualche alto funzionario del Ministero degli
Esteri a Londra in quei giorni dice, noi dobbiamo stare con i francesi e con i russi, perché questa
lotta non è per il possesso della Serbia, ma fra una Germania che aspira alla dittatura
tra politica in Europa e le potenze che vogliono restare libere. E poi c'è qualcuno che la pensa
così in Inghilterra e sono i militari. I militari sono abituati ormai a considerarsi amici dei
francesi, fare le cose insieme a loro. Sanno che sarà difficile che l'Inghilterra entri in guerra
con la Francia, perché l'opinione pubblica non lo vuole. Ed è da anni che rimuginano su questa
cosa. Anche qui è impressionante vedere come per anni e anni loro hanno pensato e discusso e ragionato
fra loro. Quando verrà la prossima guerra, cosa facciamo? C'è un aneddoto rivelatore, 1910. Un generale
inglese, molto amico dei francesi, Wilson, sta parlando con un generale francese, Foch. E Wilson gli dice,
beh, se scoppia la guerra, ammesso che veniamo ad aiutarvi, io spero, ma chi lo sa. E dice Wilson,
ma quale sarebbe il numero minimo di soldati inglesi che potrebbero davvero essere d'aiuto
alla Francia? Siamo quattro anni prima, è nel dieci. Quale sarebbe il numero minimo di soldati
inglesi che potrebbe essere d'aiuto alla Francia? E Foch risponde, un solo soldato inglese e noi faremo
in modo che venga ucciso. Perché quello che conta è che l'opinione pubblica inglese sia mobilitata
per una causa. È quasi mezzanotte, cominciamo il conto alla rovescia. Il 25 luglio arriva la
risposta serba all'ultimatum. I serbi accettano quasi tutte le condizioni. Intanto però la Serbia
rivolge un appello allo zar, per essere sicura che lo zar di Russia li sosterrà se saranno
aggrediti. Lo zar risponde ai serbi, potete contare su di noi. Quel giorno lo zar prende
una decisione simbolica, anche le cose simboliche contano in politica. Tutti gli allievi ufficiali
dell'ultimo anno che si trovano in Russia sono promossi ufficiali, lo stesso giorno alla stessa
ora, l'ora in cui scade l'ultimatum austriaco alla Serbia. Più chiaro di così non potrebbe essere.
26 luglio. L'Austria respinge la risposta serba. Avendo respinto la risposta vuol dire che farà
la guerra. Quel giorno succede una cosa a Londra. È un dettaglio. Ho riempito di dettagli questa
lezione, il che vuol dire che farò tardi. E voi avrete pazienza. Non ho avuto coraggio di tagliare
tante cose. Questo dettaglio a me sembra... Mi sembra un dettaglio a suo modo anche curioso.
Il giorno in cui l'Austria respinge la risposta serba, il ministro della marina inglese, il primo
lord dell'ammiragliato, prende di sua iniziativa una decisione. La flotta da guerra inglese è impegnata
in grandi manovre e tutta riunita con gli equipaggi al completo. Le grandi manovre finiscono
domani. Dopodiché le squadre tornano ciascuna al suo porto, i marinai vanno in licenza. Il
primo lord dell'ammiragliato di sua iniziativa ordina. La flotta domani non si scioglie, rimane
tutta unita e si trasferisce nel porto da guerra. A scapa flow, nelle orcadi, al sicuro. Ve lo racconto
anche perché il primo lord dell'ammiragliato nel 1914 è Winston Churchill, che noi siamo
abituati ad associare piuttosto alla seconda guerra mondiale e era ancora vivo quando ero
bambino io e tanti di voi, insomma, se lo ricordiamo. E però pochi ricordano che era precoce Churchill,
era un giovanotto precoce ed era già ministro della marina nel 1914. E' lui che decide che la
flotta da guerra non si scioglie ma rimane pronta e anzi si ricovera nel porto da guerra.
Il giorno dopo la borsa tedesca crolla. La notizia da Londra è sufficiente per far venire
i dubbi. Forse l'Inghilterra, dopo tutto, non rimane fuori.
Ah, c'è ancora una cosa che vi devo spiegare per spiegarvi quali condizionamenti agiscono
su questi militari e questi politici. E l'ultima cosa, spero che interrompa il nostro conto
alla rovescia. A questo punto la guerra è sicura, almeno fra Austria e Serbia è sicura.
Poi si vedrà. Per fare la guerra questi paesi devono per prima cosa decretare la mobilitazione.
Cosa vuol dire? Sono eserciti di leva. Il che vuol dire che il paese è pieno di ragazzi e di uomini
che hanno fatto il servizio militare negli anni scorsi e che possono sempre essere richiamati
se scoppia la guerra. Anzi, che è sicuro che saranno richiamati. Se scoppia la guerra
l'esercito va immediatamente gonfiato, raddoppiato, triplicato, chiamando tutti quelli che sono a casa.
Questa è la mobilitazione. È una cosa estremamente complessa perché, voi capite, si tratta di
richiamare milioni di uomini, vestirli in divisa, armarli, organizzare i reparti e metterli
sui treni che li porteranno alla frontiera. Il tutto secondo dei piani, anche quelli minuziosamente
calcolati. La mobilitazione tedesca, calcolata al minuto secondo, prevede lo spostamento
contemporaneo di 11.000 treni. I tedeschi queste cose sono abituati a farle bene. È tutto previsto
al minuto. La mobilitazione, voi lo capite, è una decisione pesantissima. Tra l'altro costa
un sacco di soldi. Quindi nessuno lo fa se la situazione non è proprio diventata molto
grave. Ma ci sono delle differenze fra un paese e l'altro. Ci sono paesi che sono lenti
a mobilitare. Uno a caso, la Russia. La Russia che è immensa e ha poche ferrovie. La Russia
ci mette mesi a mobilitare l'esercito. Quindi la Russia, se la situazione si fa grave, deve
mobilitare un po' in fretta. Non può permettersi di aspettare. Tant'è vero che il primo paese
che comincia a parlare di mobilitazione, il 26 luglio, non è l'Austria, che sta per fare
la guerra alla Serbia, ma la Serbia è piccola. Contro la Serbia non c'è bisogno di mobilitare
tutto l'esercito. Il primo paese che comincia a parlare di mobilitazione è la Russia, che
sa che ci metterà tanto tempo. Invece c'è un paese in Europa, adesso vediamo se indovinate
qual è, che è sicuro di mobilitare in frettissima. I piani sono precisissimi, tanto che loro hanno
già deciso che se mobilitano è perché c'è la guerra. Non c'è uno spazio, una differenza
fra le due decisioni. Se mobilitano, tanto vale fare la guerra subito, subito, subito.
Avete capito tutti, sono i tedeschi. Allora, lo stesso 26 luglio, in cui l'Austria respinge
la risposta serba, pur molto moderata, all'ultimatum, il cancelliere tedesco, Batman Holweg, avverte
il governo russo. E gli dice, attenzione, perché se la Russia mobilita, ci minaccia. Ma
se noi siamo minacciati, allora dobbiamo mobilitare anche noi. Ma guardate che se noi tedeschi mobilitiamo
è la guerra. Ma non possiamo ammettere che la Russia voglia scatenare una tale guerra europea.
e due, per i tedeschi la responsabilità è dei russi. Sono i russi che devono decidere
di fare un passo indietro e non mobilitare. 28 luglio, colpo di scena, il Kaiser torna
dalla crociera e gli fanno leggere la risposta serba all'ultimatum austriaco. E il Kaiser
dice, ma benissimo, è tutto quello che volevamo, anzi perfino di più. La risposta serba elimina
ogni motivo di guerra. La gioia del Kaiser quando scopre questa cosa è il primo sintomo
che i tedeschi, anche se il generale von Moltke due mesi prima ha detto adesso siamo pronti,
però un conto è dirlo in teoria. Adesso che sta succedendo davvero cominciano a comparire
i sintomi che anche i tedeschi non sono poi così sicuri di volerla fare questa guerra.
Il Kaiser è felice. La risposta serba. Mette tutto a posto, niente guerra. Peccato che quel
giorno stesso l'Austria dichiara guerra alla Serbia. I tedeschi non hanno fatto altro che
insistere. Ancora una volta dobbiamo capirla la gente di allora. C'è una tale mobilitazione
popolare in Austria. La gente è convinta, andiamo a punire questi terroristi che minacciano
il mondo. C'è un tale, ve ne do un esempio, Sigmund Freud. Freud che è austriaco, vive a
Vienna. Ha 58 anni, è già un uomo maturo, ha vissuto tutta la sua vita nell'impero austriaco.
Freud, quando l'Austria dichiara guerra alla Serbia, Freud dice, scrive, non so più ma comunque
è accertata la cosa. Per la prima volta da 30 anni mi sento veramente austriaco. Per la prima
volta penso che questo impero forse ha un futuro. E poi questo è veramente un virgolettato. Tutta la
mia libido è rivolta all'Austria-Ungheria. Questo era il 28 luglio. Il 29 luglio la Russia comincia
i preparativi di mobilitazione. Cioè esattamente la cosa che i tedeschi gli avevano detto, non fatelo
perché se no è la guerra. La Russia mobilita perché ha paura e neanche i russi vorrebbero
fare la guerra. Come si scopre da un altro episodio che comincia questo 29 luglio, che
è molto curioso, che è anch'esso tipico di questa strana epoca, perché l'Europa di questi
anni è veramente strana. È sospesa fra la modernità, la democrazia parlamentare, liberale
e l'arcaismo di questi imperi dinastici dove imperatori e re hanno ancora potere. Il 29 luglio
comincia la storia dei telegrammi di Nicky a Willy e di Willy a Nicky. Comincia con un
telegramma dello zar di Russia, Nicola, che quel 29 luglio manda un telegramma al Kaiser
Guglielmo, contro cui sta per mobilitare l'esercito. Lo zar Nicola manda un telegramma al Kaiser
in inglese. Questo è anche molto significativo, dà l'idea di che cos'è ormai l'Inghilterra.
50 anni prima, se uno zar doveva scrivere a un re di Prussia, gli scriveva in francese.
Adesso invece loro si parlano e si scrivono in inglese. Tenete conto, per apprezzare la
situazione, che lo zar Nicola, l'imperatore Guglielmo e il re d'Inghilterra, Giorgio,
sono cugini primi. Sono cugini primi, sono tutti nipoti della regina Vittoria. Ricordate
la regina Vittoria dell'Ottocento, morta nel 1900, erotti, insomma. Sono tutti i suoi
nipotini. Sono cugini primi, si danno del tu, si chiamano col diminutivo. Dunque lo zar
di Russia il 29 luglio manda un telegramma al Kaiser. Sono contento che sei tornato dalla
crociera. Il momento è serio e ho bisogno del tuo aiuto. Una guerra ignobile è stata
dichiarata contro un paese debole. Lo zar ovviamente si schiera con la Serbia. In nome
della nostra vecchia amicizia ti prego di fare tutto quello che puoi per fermare i tuoi
alleati, cioè gli austriaci. Firmato Niki. Il Kaiser risponde. Risponde lo stesso giorno
in inglese dicendo ma guarda la cosa dall'altro punto di vista. La Serbia è stato terrorista,
l'Austria è stata a diritto e così via. Dai su dovete capire voi russi fate voi un
passo indietro. Firmato Willy. Si scrivono per quattro giorni una dozzina di telegrammi
Niki a Willy e Willy a Niki fino al primo agosto quando Willy dichiara guerra a Niki.
Comunque non precorriamo i tempi abbiamo ancora appunto quattro giorni da sistemare. 29 luglio
i tedeschi sono furibondi contro questi stupidi russi che non hanno capito che mobilità
quando provocano la guerra. Il generale von Moltke. La Russia si è schierata a fianco di un
paese criminale, di un covo di terroristi. Così incomincerà lo sbranamento reciproco degli stati
civili europei. Una guerra è sempre il generale von Moltke che annienterà la civiltà di quasi
tutta Europa per decenni. Però bisogna comunque farla questa guerra perché nessuno si vuole tirare
indietro. Qui viene fuori anche come dire un tratto quasi schizofrenico di questa classe dirigente
che in realtà ha chiarissimo che questa guerra sarà una catastrofe però al tempo stesso non ci si può
tirare indietro e perdere la faccia. Lo facciano gli altri di fare un passo indietro. Noi no.
In Germania c'è un'ulteriore spaccatura a questo punto fra i militari e i politici. I militari dicono
la guerra è inevitabile perciò facciamola subito, attacchiamo noi, dateci l'ordine di mobilitazione.
I politici dicono invece un momento perché dal punto di vista dei politici è fondamentale far
vedere che non è la Germania che ha la colpa della guerra, è tutta colpa dei russi e dei francesi.
La Germania no. Dunque perché ci tengono tanto a questo i politici tedeschi? Per tanti motivi,
forse anche per salvare la faccia, per amor proprio, per senso dell'onore, ma poi ci tengono
per l'opinione pubblica tedesca. L'opinione pubblica conta anche in Germania, c'è un enorme
partito socialista in Germania. Cosa diranno i socialisti? Se la gente pensa che siamo stati
aggrediti allora non ci saranno problemi, infatti è proprio quello che succederà. La Germania ritarda
la mobilitazione e la popolazione tedesca andrà alla guerra convinta che la Germania innocente è
stata aggredita e che perciò bisogna difenderla. E poi bisogna evitare che l'Inghilterra entri in
guerra. Se l'Inghilterra vede che la Germania fa di tutto per evitarla, la guerra magari rimane fuori.
Dopotutto gli inglesi, insomma, si è capito che vorrebbero restare fuori se solo possono.
Ma c'è un altro problema che rende molto difficile ai tedeschi tener fuori l'Inghilterra
dalla guerra. E l'ultimo, come dire, problema che tiro fuori dal cappello, il Belgio. Voi direte
cosa c'entra il Belgio? C'entra. Il Belgio è un piccolo paese neutrale che gode di una garanzia
firmata da tutte le grandi potenze, compresa la Germania e l'Inghilterra, che garantiscono che
il Belgio sarà sempre neutrale. E questa è una cosa che agli inglesi importa molto, perché nella
loro visione dell'Europa il Belgio, con i suoi porti affacciati sulla manica, anversa, è un
collegamento fondamentale per l'Inghilterra. Noi inglesi potremmo litigare con la Francia, non importa,
finché c'è il Belgio abbiamo un collegamento con l'Europa. Quindi agli inglesi della Serbia non
importa niente, ma del Belgio gli importerebbe sì. E perché mai dovrebbero preoccuparsi i tedeschi
del Belgio? Per via dei piani. Perché lo Stato maggiore tedesco ha un piano perfetto per fare la
guerra contro la Francia e la Russia e vincerla in poche settimane. È tutto calcolato. I russi sono
lenti, perciò noi mandiamo tutto l'esercito, i famosi 11.000 treni, contro la Francia. La invadiamo
e chiudiamo la guerra in poche settimane. Però, per invadere la Francia e aggirare l'esercito
francese, scusate se entro in queste considerazioni strategiche, i militari tedeschi hanno deciso che
bisogna passare dal Belgio. È il famoso piano Schliffen, che qualcuno si ricorderà, perfezionato
per anni e anni. I militari tedeschi dicono se volete che vi vinciamo la guerra, il piano è questo,
dobbiamo passare dal Belgio. Sta a voi politici vedere come gestire la faccenda.
Il 29 luglio il Kaiser e il cancelliere tedesco Bertmann-Holweg si rendono conto che se la
scommessa è che l'Inghilterra resti fuori dalla guerra, bisogna però capire come fare con questa
cosa del Belgio, perché noi tedeschi invaderemo il Belgio, ormai è già deciso. Allora, il 29 luglio
il Kaiser e il cancelliere prendono una decisione cruciale, che sarà poi giudicata concordemente
la decisione più stupida che i tedeschi abbiano preso in quei giorni. Scrivono a Londra, al governo
inglese, garantendo. Primo, che se c'è la guerra contro la Francia, gli inglesi possono
stare tranquilli, la Germania non ha nessuna aspirazione territoriale, non vogliamo prenderci
dei pezzi di Francia, quindi non vogliamo turbare l'equilibrio europeo. Secondo, i tedeschi
assicurano il governo inglese che se per caso durante la guerra dovessero essere costretti
a invadere il Belgio, però alla fine della guerra lo sgombreranno. E se i belgi faranno
i bravi e non si mostreranno ostili, gli pagheranno anche i danni. E finalmente i tedeschi scrivono
a Londra che dopo tutto, però pensiamoci un po' bene, perché noi tedeschi e voi inglesi
potremmo ancora metterci d'accordo, insieme siamo fortissimi, ci spartiamo il mondo, che
vi importa a voi che siete amici della Francia, che vi importa del Belgio, spartiamoci il mondo
fra noi. A Londra si vedono arrivare questo messaggio e rimangono trasecolati.
Un alto funzionario del Ministero degli Esteri commenta queste sorprendenti offerte, meritano
un solo commento, gettano una pessima luce sullo statista che le ha formulate. Oltretutto
gli inglesi dicono, ma come questi ci stanno dicendo che invaderanno il Belgio? Così per
iscritto ce l'hanno messo. Gray chiama l'ambasciatore tedesco, il principe Lichnowski, e gli dice,
ma guardate che se la guerra scoppia noi non possiamo restare fuori e a questo punto noi
entriamo in guerra anche noi, a fianco dei nostri amici. Gray dice anche una cosa che in quei giorni
stanno ripetendo tutti, quasi ossessiva. Se la guerra scoppia sarà la più grande catastrofe
che il mondo abbia visto. Però l'Inghilterra non può fare questo accordo con la Germania,
tradire i suoi amici sarebbe una vergogna incancellabile, perciò pensateci bene a Berlino.
E tre, per gli inglesi la responsabilità di tutto è a Berlino, è a Berlino che devono fare
un passo indietro. A queste notizie da Londra la reazione tedesca è incontrollata. Il Kaiser
annota sulla comunicazione. Gray è una volgare canaglia. Gli inglesi sono dei farabutti. L'Inghilterra
si assume ora l'intera responsabilità di una guerra mondiale. E quattro, per i tedeschi
la responsabilità è degli inglesi. Quel giorno, 29 luglio, l'ambasciatore tedesco a Bruxelles,
Von Bello Usalesk, riceve un plico sigillato da Berlino, con l'ordine di non aprirlo fino
a quando non arriveranno nuove comunicazioni telegrafiche. Altro dettaglio inutile, ma ormai
ci siamo, ve lo infliggo lo stesso. Von Bello Usalesk è un diplomatico di carriera che ha l'abitudine
di dire, scherzando, che lui porta sfortuna. Era in Cina, è scoppiata la rivolta dei boxer.
Era in Turchia, è scoppiata la rivoluzione dei giovani turchi. Però poi dice, adesso però
sono tranquillo, sono in Belgio, a Bruxelles non succederà mai niente.
Stringiamo i tempi, se no vi faccio fare notte. Nella notte, fra il 29 e il 30 luglio,
a Berlino non vanno a dormire, perché le notizie da Londra li hanno gettati nel panico. Sta
venendo fuori che l'Inghilterra entrerà in guerra. Il 30 luglio, alle 3 del mattino,
Batman Holweg, cancelliere tedesco, chiama Vienna e dice, ma non avete capito niente,
volete davvero fare la guerra alla Serbia? Andateci piano, rallentate. La Germania non
intende farsi trascinare in una guerra assurda per colpa dell'Austria. Immaginate la faccia
che fanno a Vienna, dove fino al giorno prima i tedeschi gli dicevano, andate avanti. Quindi
5 per i tedeschi la responsabilità adesso è a Vienna. Però nel frattempo, siamo ormai
al 30 luglio, la Russia, dopo finiti i preparativi, che già solo i preparativi occupano un po'
di giorni, il 30 luglio la Russia ordina la mobilitazione generale. A Berlino i militari
vanno dal governo e dicono, oh, mobilitiamo anche noi subito. Il governo dice, aspettiamo
ancora un giorno, perché magari a Vienna riescono a inventarsi qualcosa. In questo
giorno, 30 luglio, a Berlino la crisi fra militari e politici rasenta, non dico il colpo
di Stato, ma l'alto tradimento sì. Quel pomeriggio esce un giornale del pomeriggio,
all'epoca c'erano i giornali del pomeriggio, in Germania, che annuncia l'ordine di mobilitazione.
Non è vero. Il giornale viene sequestrato, poi si scopre che è lo Stato maggiore che ha
fatto filtrare la falsa notizia per mettere il governo davanti al fatto compiuto.
Il generale von Moltke telefona al suo collega austriaco, il comandante austriaco Conrad.
L'Austria non ha ancora mobilitato, fra l'altro, perché l'Austria fa le cose con tale lentezza
che non ha ancora mobilitato. Ecco, e Moltke dice a Conrad, mobilitate subito, perché se
mobilitate voi dovremmo mobilitare anche noi. Insomma, i militari tedeschi fanno di tutto
per costringere il governo a mobilitare. Il governo tiene ancora duro, però è nel panico
più totale. Quel giorno affiora un altro aspetto caratteristico delle comunicazioni
di quegli ultimissimi giorni. La sensazione che tutti hanno che sta succedendo una cosa
che nessuno voleva e che non si riesce più a impedire. Al Consiglio dei Ministri il cancelliere
tedesco Batman Holbeg dice «Tutti i governi, compreso quello russo, e la maggioranza dei popoli
erano per se stessi pacifici, ma il sasso ha cominciato a rotolare». Ecco, che è una
bella dichiarazione di resa della politica. Il sasso rotola e noi non sappiamo più cosa
fare. Quel giorno la borsa di New York crolla. 31 luglio c'è il fuso orario, al mattino
arriva la notizia di New York, la borsa di Londra crolla. La chiudono alle 10 del mattino
per limitare le perdite. La Germania non mobilita ancora, ma manda un ultimatum alla
Russia. Avete cominciato la mobilitazione? Sospendete! Se entro mezzanotte sospendete
bene, altrimenti è la guerra. A Londra, quel 31 luglio, Gray, ministro degli esteri, ormai
è convinto che la guerra è inevitabile e che l'Inghilterra deve entrare, ma è in minoranza
nel governo. Il governo continua a dire «noi, non c'entriamo niente». Gray fa quello che
può, manda un telegramma a Parigi e uno a Berlino, chiedendo la garanzia che sarà rispettata
la neutralità del Belgio. I francesi rispondono entro un'ora, i tedeschi non rispondono.
Primo agosto, Gray parla al governo, definisce la Germania un aggressore pericoloso quanto
Napoleone e lascia capire che lui si dimetterà se l'Inghilterra non entra in guerra. Ma la
maggioranza dei ministri è contraria. La maggioranza dei ministri minaccia di dimettersi
se si fa la guerra. Fuori dalla porta c'è l'ambasciatore francese, Cambon, che aspetta
che in tutti quei giorni non ha fatto altro. Voi capite il mestiere dell'ambasciatore francese
a Londra in quei giorni. Garantirci che, visto che la guerra sta per scoppiare, gli inglesi
entrano in guerra con noi, siamo così amici. Gray è costretto a uscire e dire a Cambon
che non c'è nessuna garanzia, il governo non concede niente. Cambon entra nell'ufficio
di un amico lì al Ministero degli Esteri inglese, l'amico lo descrive bianco come un
cencio, sul punto di scoppiare a piangere. L'ambasciatore francese crolla su una sedia
e dice all'amico, ci mollano. Intanto però tutto precipita. Quel primo agosto la Germania
dichiara guerra alla Russia. È la prima dichiarazione di guerra fra grandi potenze.
Perché la Germania dichiara guerra? Perché è la prassi. Abbiamo mandato l'ultimatum,
abbiamo detto agli russi entro mezzanotte sospendete, i russi non hanno sospeso, perciò
dobbiamo dichiarare guerra. La sera prima si sono trovati a casa di Batman Holweg i ministri
per stilare la dichiarazione di guerra alla Russia. Il ministro della Marina Tirpitz ha detto
ma perché dobbiamo dichiarare guerra? Se abbiamo fatto di tutto per non dare l'impressione
che siamo noi gli aggressori, perché dobbiamo dichiarare guerra noi? Gli rispondono che i
tecnici del Ministero degli Esteri hanno detto che si fa così. La prassi è quella, hai mandato
l'ultimatum, dopo l'ultimatum devi dichiarare guerra. Lo stesso giorno, primo agosto, alle
4 del pomeriggio, la Germania dichiara guerra alla Russia e ordina la mobilitazione generale.
Per loro è davvero la stessa cosa. Ma c'è ancora spazio per una commedia, un equivoco,
grottesco. Alle 5 del pomeriggio arriva a Berlino un telegramma dall'ambasciatore a Londra,
il principe Liknovsky. Liknovsky dice, devo vedere Gray, il ministro degli Esteri inglese,
fra poco. Mi ha convocato stamattina. Mi è sembrato di capire che l'Inghilterra vuol proporre
un accordo. Se noi ci impegniamo a non attaccare la Francia, anche l'Inghilterra e la Francia
si impegnano a restare neutrali. Il telegramma arriva a Berlino e suscita un pandemonio. Il
Kaiser e Betman Holberg, cancelliere, dicono, fantastico, non dobbiamo più fare la guerra
contro Francia e Russia, solo contro la Russia. Se l'Inghilterra e la Francia restano fuori,
siamo a posto. Basta solo cambiare gli ordini di mobilitazione. Tutto contro la Russia. Chiamano
il generale von Moltke, che è al comando dell'esercito che organizza la grande mobilitazione.
11.000 treni si sono già messi in movimento. In quel preciso momento, in tutte le stazioni,
in tutte le caserme della Germania, arriva il telegramma con gli ordini segreti. Si è messo
in movimento tutto. Richiamano von Moltke al palazzo imperiale. Von Moltke, vi devo dire questo
di von Moltke. Lui non è un grande generale, lo faranno fuori presto dal comando. È lì
soprattutto perché è il nipote di un gran duomo. Nell'Ottocento c'era stato un altro
von Moltke, un famosissimo generale prussiano vincitore di tutte le guerre. Ecco, il von Moltke
è il giovane, è lì più che altro perché è nipote di quel grande zio, ma è un uomo
dei nervi un po' fragili. Arriva al palazzo imperiale e gli dicono, guarda, telegramma da
Londra, probabilmente l'Inghilterra e la Francia restano fuori. Fantastico! Cambia gli ordini
di mobilitazione, tutto contro la Russia. A von Moltke viene un accidente. Si mette
a piangere e dichiara che non si può fare. È già tutto in movimento, 11.000 treni, milioni
di persone, tutto calcolato al secondo. Non si può fare, insistono. Moltke, che ripeto,
è sull'oro del collasso, quella sera tornerà a casa, avrà un infarto. Ma tiene duro e dice
non si può fare. Il Kaiser gli dice, suo zio mi avrebbe dato un'altra risposta. Moltke
è un uomo finito. Intanto però la mobilitazione non si può cambiare e quindi continua tutto
secondo i piani. Quella sera i tedeschi invadono il Lussemburgo. Primo passo per l'invasione
del Belgio. Però prima di invadere il Belgio bisogna rispettare le forme, dargli l'ultimatum.
Il 2 agosto, a Fonbello, a Zaleska, a Bruxelles, arriva il telegramma. Apri il plico sigillato,
porta l'ultimatum al Belgio, facendo finta che sia appena arrivato. Ce l'ha lì da vari
giorni, ma... L'ultimatum al Belgio dice ai Belgi, è un cumulo di bugie. Qui comincia
un altro aspetto, sto finendo, ma è l'ultimo aspetto un po' grottesco di questa situazione.
Voi avete visto com'è complicato e al tempo stesso paurosamente semplice l'itinerario
che porta alla guerra. Con tutto questo i tedeschi rimangono convinti che per mandare
un ultimatum o dichiarare guerra a qualcuno bisogna avere dei pretesti, delle scuse. E
quindi dicono ai Belgi. Sappiamo da fonte sicura che la Francia sta per invadere il Belgio.
Noi tedeschi, voi capite, per la nostra sicurezza dobbiamo venire anche noi in Belgio. Ma non vorremmo
che i Belgi lo interpretassero come un atto di ostilità. Se il Belgio rimane neutrale e si
comporta bene, i tedeschi alla fine della guerra lo evacueranno, promesso. I Belgi decidono di
resistere. Quella sera a Berlino, a casa di Beethoven, a Holweg, si prepara la dichiarazione
di guerra alla Francia. L'ammiraglio von Tirpitz dice ma perché dobbiamo dichiarare guerra anche
alla Francia? Aspettiamo che ce la dichiarino loro! Gli spiegano che secondo le regole bisogna
fare così. Anche la dichiarazione di guerra alla Francia è un cumulo di bugie. Aerei francesi
hanno sorvolato la Germania, hanno gettato bombe, hanno ammazzato civili, perciò la Francia
si è messa in guerra da sola e così via. Evidentemente anche quando si fa la politica
di potenza c'è questo bisogno di aggrapparsi a qualcosa, per l'opinione pubblica forse.
A me torna in mente Colin Powell all'ONU con la provetta delle armi batteriologiche di
Saddam Hussein. Ma insomma, comunque, quella sera, 2 agosto, a Londra, Gray viene a sapere
dell'ultimatum tedesco al Belgio e strappa finalmente al governo inglese l'ordine di
mobilitazione. Parecchi ministri si dimettono. Quella sera un diplomatico americano a Bruxelles
annota sul suo diario. Che strano, fino a qualche giorno fa si parlava tanto della Serbia.
Adesso non ne parla più nessuno, è come se se la fossero tutti dimenticata. 3 agosto
siamo davvero alla fine. La Germania dichiara guerra alla Francia. Gray strappa alla Camera dei
Comuni, finalmente, è il primo Parlamento che entra in gioco e che fa qualcosa. In questa
crisi che è stata tutta gestita dai governi e dai sovrani, Gray strappa alla Camera dei
Comuni l'autorizzazione a mandare ai tedeschi un ultimatum. Se invadono il Belgio è la guerra.
4 agosto, i tedeschi invadono il Belgio. L'ambasciatore inglese arriva con l'ultimatum
dal cancelliere Batman Holwig, senza sapere che quel mattino i tedeschi hanno già cominciato
all'invasione del Belgio. E l'intera vicenda si conclude, anche questo mio racconto si conclude,
con due frasi celebri. Una celeberrima, una un po' meno. La frase celeberrima è quella del
cancelliere tedesco Batman Holwig, che quando arriva l'ambasciatore inglese con l'ultimatum
gli fa una scenata e gli dice ma come, ma voi inglesi, un popolo germanico, anche voi come noi,
ci colpite alle spalle in questo modo, ma per cosa? Ma per la garanzia che avevamo dato al Belgio
della sua neutralità, voi ci fate questo, vi assumete questa responsabilità, è tutto
per un pezzo di carta. Che è una frase che appunto è passata alla storia come emblema
diciamo di questa politica che pensa di poter firmare i trattati e poi insomma se uno vuole
poi fa finta che non ci siano, ecco i trattati. L'altra frase storica è un po' meno storica
ma insomma è del Kaiser, il quale ricordiamolo era cugino del re d'Inghilterra e dello zar
e si chiamavano tutti col nomignolo e si davano del tu e quando è ovvio a questo punto che c'è
la guerra contro la Russia, contro la Francia e anche contro l'Inghilterra e sono tutti nipotini
della regina Vittoria, vi ricordate? Il Kaiser dichiara. Chi l'avrebbe detto che Giorgi e
Nicchi mi stavano per tradire, se fosse vissuta mia nonna non l'avrebbe mai permesso.
Grazie.
Grazie e buonanotte a tutti e a domani.